[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soir à chelles balle je le note de plus
en plus au fait je suis un enfant du paf
quoi si jean luc hees à partir de
l'avarice
ça fait deux semaines dans taxi anglais
derrière et dans ta tronche et à eux
vas-y mon bébé haye a dû me fier ce soir
cyril c'est quoi quand je dis qu'il ya
du lourd pendant les pubs pendant les
magnétos vous savez je suis lundi que je
vois tout je sais tout je dénonce tout
et on commence comme chaque semaine
cyril avec la séquence star du paf a
d'ailleurs vous en êtes l'invité
d'honneur prendre ton oreille pour une
trousse
c'est le type qui va sortir ses débuts
dans certains seconds inside tous un peu
et on commence tout de suite avec baba
qui a en commun avec stéphane bern
mais également avec picsou qui adore
l'histoire c'est chez moi aussi chantre
un terrain livres d'histoire glosaient
et on continue avec maîtresse bonvoisin
attention quand elle parle
il faut l'écouter elle est violente
[Musique]
oui ou non
une oeuvre l'état catella gazin tu fais
ton je me prend pas
/
vous connaissez la création changé
d'avis comme de chemise
avec cyril découvrir l'expression changé
d'avis comme de tuer la ba ba je défonce
eu une casse les couilles
messaoud mais si ce monsieur vous
demande par exemple de recul et je ne
m'en fais attention un nouveau beau
gosse se tourne à table ce n'est pas un
chroniqueur mais un invité
il est très beau le louer ensemble bien
des biens s'est incliné hier soir c'est
vrai je trouve qu'ils te vient cette
habilité
[Musique]
petite question autres mais combien de
temps steevy boulay peut-il rester la
bouche ouverte
top chrono
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour une fois c'est pas moi qui s'est
pris un vent dans sa gueule
bonsoir comment ça tu as si camille
natale un petit conseil si vous voulez
sortir nam n'est jamais tu fais des bons
voisins
elle a un talent on n'a pas encore vu
dans l'émission alain de téléphone au 39
81 pour cyril n'a plus d'oseille plus du
tout j'ai peu de 400 gares et j'étais
obligé de mettre un short
il vous avait manqué il est de retour
s'est plaint mardi le bouc et les
chipmunks l épilation du losc et avec
cyril qui est toujours très affectueux
avec le stand by rahma donnant qui dit
qu'un gros bâtard
je dis qu'ils ont pas tort
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est mon fils pendant les pubs d'aller
embêter benjamin c'est mon frérot
d'amour mais heureusement c'est vrai que
c'est mon bonheur d'abord mais ça fait
très longtemps qu'on sait pas chamailler
d'ailleurs quand même celui hier déjà la
casse web apps a pas vraiment parce que
si un mouvement il m'a appris à un
mouvement de huy de baston très
franchement très efficace parce qu'il
faut que vous sachiez quelque chose jama
castaldi quand il était à peine je vous
dise terreur non mais vraiment moi je
prends des agneaux matériel même voie
c'est qu'ils me disaient genre ouais
benjamin c'est la terreur de tpr à jour
tous les autres animateurs avaient peur
de lui
il mettait des coups de pression c'était
un nerveux et c'est vrai non là ça a
toujours été au rendez vous et pas le
malin pour battre benjamin peu ou pas
donc non mes origines je fais pas le
malin si vous étiez la terreur atef non
mais se dit la vérité révocation un peu
comme vous voilà j'étais comme vous tous
et bein moi je sois on a testé j'étais à
tf1 en même temps qu on me voit sa
matinale et j'ai cassé une porte avec
des neiges et la callas et voilà il a
essayé de faire ce sera perdre les
pannes berne et d'enfants d'ici là je
vous dis à mes sincères de terreur lui
une terreur ton avait peur de lui à quoi
j'ai vu qu'il est venu ici qu'il a
compris que c'est un bouffon
je t'adore et tu le sais c'est vraiment
mener c c'est mon kiff voilà c'est mon
équipe de l'avoir été bons à ça j'ai vu
le chirurgien ce matin bâti très beau ça
va mieux ah oui c'est vrai mais ça va
mieux mais je sais rien en fait j'ai un
premier que les déciles en fait
bref écrasés par les paupières
maintenant ils ont été libérés a dit
l'enquêté écrasé et qui se relève que
les ressorts une histoire à la con
je te le jure qui est très beau ce soir
ça va mieux mais dante est très beau ça
commence à aller bien mais tu es
vraiment à gauche maintenant j'ai
compris ça t'a d'ocha préval après
benjamin que ça déchire il ya un autre
chroniqueur qui en passe d'être unie
autour de cette table lors qu'ils
savaient qu'ils autant c'est guillaume
genton guillaume genton alors pour ceux
qui ne savent pas guillaume genton
propose des défis tarifs et aux invités
de touche pas à mon poste même des
invités très sérieux parfois ils leur
demandent de placer des mots pendant
l'émission comme ça au calme sauf que
parfois bas ça commence à se voir
puisque c'est plus des mots ce sont deux
phrases toute entière qui demandent de
faire passer aux invités les défis de
genton m'a regardé et je peux vous dire
que là cette semaine et encore du lourd
[Musique]
ou pas là vendredi
voilà c'est dit
à 110
alors que tu dises humala qui cherche
voilà qui change
très choqué on va devoir donner la
parole aux anciens
nicolas g isabelle delphine nicolas non
mais on nous prend pour des dindons à
nous montrer les images fois déduit le
but de the voice est quand même de
choisir et de mettre en avant un artiste
qui va plaire au public
pernikoff témala qui jeta mais il ya des
limites il ya des gens qui en font un
modèle d insulte à tout va et à tout le
monde je peux vous répondre arrête
complètement suranné oui ça c'est un
pari avec
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la plus amère gd des tacos 3
[Applaudissements]
loto
j'adore pratiquer sa leçon débat
d'autres encore bravo tu perds beaucoup
d'autres mais pourquoi tu es
balakrishnan il est pas autre chose
qu'il fallait que ça c'est drôle ça
sorte naturellement chez marx et après
tu es mal acquis jeta aulas j'ai quelque
chose sur vous cyril dix mois que c'est
vrai que ça fait 15 jours qu'on s'est
pas vue et franchement si vous m'avez
manqué n'arrive pas et du coup j'ai
allégé ce nano est un best of mais oui
et donc vous avez manqué et j'ai
accumulé plein de dossiers sur vos
séries mais vous allez voir c'est pas
très méchant puisque quand cyril reçoit
ses invités
il n'y a pas d'autres animateurs dans le
paf qui savent les recevoir comme lui je
vous ai analysé et je vous trouve plus
aimant flûte ou plus sensible plus
aimant plus méticuleux perspicace moi je
cacochyme moi j'aimerais bien trouver
mais les flux
tu sais ce que c'est mais les flux mais
il sait ce que ça mais les physiciens
c'est ce que c'est mais les filles ça
veut dire que vous êtes tout comme le
miel chérifien est ce que ton corps
c'est oui je crois que c'est un
médicament est retiré reçoit ses invités
battant ça qu'on est prêt si tu avais
regardées jours c'est vrai
les concernant ça va marcher reda montée
était exceptionnelle réunion ce qu
attend ce moment
toronto parle de toi les mots merci
d'être là autorités c'est un amour merci
pour votre dédicace on remercie pour
votre dédicace et grandes villes et sur
ma tenue je commence à vous êtes un
amour merci d'être là aux oiseaux tant
chéri merci de koh lanta porto ou baby
commencer je t'aime fort merci de cacher
ses visites amour toujours vraiment et
bosal ça va les beaux gosses ça va les
beaux gosses à gérer leurs sonorités
nicoletta je l'aimais ça fait des années
que la connais je l adore vous avez des
brodeurs st amour ils nous regardent
tous les soirs bah oui mais j'invite des
gens qui aiment bien les joueurs ils
sont beaux gosses et j'ai bien dit
fatima elle est excellente à chaque fois
qu'elle vient à franchement elle se
défend contre tout le monde
il n'y a pas de la place pour tout le
monde dans notre coeur de notre votre
invité on n'a pas bien su si vous
l'aviez alors mais au final j'ai sur ma
je vous dire j'ai tous vos livres sur
gée l'audit de delphine jeux livres de
bd mg litre de raymond voillat si vous
mais aussi non je lis votre aussi les
lumières il faut que j'aille il ya de la
place pour tout le monde dans ce petit
coeur serré les rangs de repartir je
doute moi pense que c'est normal que je
puisse plus d'un petit peu serré la voix
de repartir a tué 126
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la renégociation c'est pour quand celle
avant de repartir lundi que vous devez
être un petit peu le dawa sur ce plateau
je voulais faire un peu le dawa quoi
avec stevie j ai fait une révélation
fracassante cette semaine il a craqué
sur l'un des chroniqueurs
alors pour ceux qui n'étaient pas là je
vous propose de regarder le magnéto qui
va suivre vous allez voir que ce
chroniqueur en question n'a pas fermé sa
porte
il n'a pas fermé toutes ses portes c'est
le retour jeu qui va partir en sucette
sur la tête de thatta ça va partir en
sucette sur la tête de thatta nicolas
pernikoff de plus en plus beau celui ci
a franchement regardez
merci mais vraiment vous avez énormément
de chance physiquement moralement
intellectuelle plastique faciliter les
gens une aventure avec nicolas pernikoff
a sans aucun doute aidé à me donner
aucun commentaire jusqu'ici je saute
dessus
non c'est pas ça
[Applaudissements]
j'espère temps mais j'ai peur j'ai pas
envie de moyens
[Musique]
arthur
gagné
[Applaudissements]